Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario Maker.
Now we're still on the Hundred Mario Challenge
and we're still on 'Normal'.
Uh, after I finish the 'Normal' one
I'm gonna start up the 'Expert' one and...
See what kinda hell it throws at me.
Pretty sure I can just run from this.
Run! Run Forrest! Okay.
That was the exact answer that I needed.
Heh.. Heaah... Ah shit, I need to throw it, I forgot.
Bang! Ah shit, that hardly did anything that I needed it to do.
Oh god, this is the exact opposite of the good.
Ok, I'm just gonna get in-
oh God, don't steal my- why would you get in there?
How did you get in there, that's not f-
Oh, fuck you! Come on, you BASTARD!
You stole MY RIDE!
What is this, Grand Theft Mario? Screw you!
Alright, here we go. AAAH
Ok, now that we got that (fbbbt)
Some of them are dead now,
Aww, I'm dead too, I was one of the 'some'.
Come on, come on, come on.
I can do this, I can do this.
Once I just learn the trick, I'll be able to do it fast and efficiently.
babedubabedubabedubabedubabeduBOINK
And go right through, into- here we go!
Alright, we got it.
We got tongue and fire action going on.
Oh, I love the little angry face on him.
It's so adorable, aww, it's so cool.
*Curly "whoopwoowhoowhoo" noise*
Oh, hello. Uh, boink?
Oh, I'll just eat some of that, thank you.
WUWUBWUBWUBWUBWUBWUBWUBWUBWUB
Ah, shitty.
Ah- wha-no!
The end was right there!
I didn't know the end was right there,
I would've gone right for it!
What do you think, I'm honorable?
I'm gonna fight a fair fight?
No, I'm gonna skip straight to the end if I can,
and then run away as fast as I am
humanly capable of doing so!
*Fart noise*
Alright, get ready, get ready for the pain,
get ready for the thunder.
Bloomp!
Oh shit, come on, come on, no!
No! Come on, oh!
Oh God, it was right there.
[laughing]
What is in your mouth, Yoshi?
Yoshi, what is in your mouth?
Oh ok, thank you for catching me.
I'm glad that you were here for me, in the end,
when I needed you the most.
Let's just squat down here.
You keep holding your breath, little buddy
until you eventually turn blrlue.
I always liked the blue Yoshi better anyway,
so I'm glad you're appreciating my needs.
Oh, I got a new world record!
Cool! That one was nuts.
Mmm.
Delicious water, very professional of me,
drinking it while I record.
But it's ok, you guys understand.
Ok.
Got these two and I'm gonna start the expert ones
and see where that one takes me
because it's going to be NUTS
Let's go down! Oh God, this is moving really fastly.
AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AW SHIT OH GOD hehehehehe
I guess I could have gone above 'em
that probably would have been very advantageous for me
maybe I can't go above 'em for too long.
My happy-go-lucky little propeller dude.
Umm...
I don't know if this is where I was supposed to be going...
There's a little drawing there of a little helicopter by some Thwomps.
They all seem so peaceful and sleeping.
I never did understand HOW Thwomps were able to just hover in mid-air
and if anything, why were they only able to go UP
or go DOWN smash?
Why can't they do an UP smash?
I guess that's the advent of the GIANT pillars of dildo coming out at you from out of the walls.
At the same time, I guess whenever they go back up, they go back up real, lethargic like
(whispering) So, I don't know.
(whispering) It's a mystery of Mario. Who knows these things?
(normal voice) I certainly do not.
Ok.
'Thwomp falls'. Good name.
Alright, this is the last one in the 'Normal'
and then we're gonna roll right on to the 'Expert's.
(whispering) I don't know how I'm gonna do with that one.
The answer is probably not very good,
but I'm gonna try my be-
What is this?
Uh..
uh..
is there..
Hehe...uh...
I'm no fool!
I'm no fool, here,
but it, it see- Ok, here we go.
What.. what am I supposed to-
Oh. Oh. Oh, ok.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, not yet.
(girly screaming) Ah! Oh no, we're gonna make it!
[groans]
Ok, we made it somehow,
I don't know how we did that.
Oh God, this was a mistake.
A mistake, mistakes!
Oh, mistakes were made, mistakes were made, mistakes were made.
(laughing) Alright, try that again.
I think the end-
I- what was this level named?
'Super super easy'.
Ok. I'm sure, I'm sure.
I'm sure it is.
Whoops, didn't mean to do that.
Drop down, there we go.
Ha-boing!
Alright.
See what happens, see where we're going with this one.
Oh God, missing it, missing it,
missing it, oof, oof, oof.
Oof. Ah, don't get me!
I'm just a poor-
Uh oh. Woo!
And-oh. Ok.
I'm just a poor little baboo.
Don't mind me.
Here we go-
Ah, boing!
Ok. Oh, what the- no
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No raining hammers.
Oh God, oh God, mistakes were made.
Where was I supposed to go with that one?
I guess I was supposed to still have the propeller beanie, but
I, I lost it.
So if I lose it then I'm n- I'm just screwed?
This seems a little- this seems a little unforgiving,
to be honest.
I think they threw in one expert
level towards the end here, just to mess with people.
Ok.
Oh God.
Oh gesh.
Oh geersh, oh geersh.
Oh geliursh.
Oh gersh. Woo!
Go down.
Ok. Now this one,
is gonna go a lot easier
because I am going to wait
until the very end to
do this, and then, woah, go down, go down.
Ah, don't lose it- oh come on!
Why'd that one guy throw that way? Aw shiiit!
Why did that one guy throw the other way
when everyone else-
why did he have to go against the grain?
Doesn't everyone know that you're not
supposed to be original and individual?
This is
bullshit!
This is BULLSHIT
-try this again.
This time with a little less suck.
I mean I-
I normally add gratuitous amounts of suck
to every game that I play but
this time I'm going to try to mix it up!
Just put some-
Noo.
No! NO!
You proved my point, game!
I am suck!
Alright. Take- take-
take four!
Shit- fuck- aw, fuck.
Shit, balls and fudgebags.
Heh.
Try going this way.
This is gonna work out.
See, it worked out.
Alright...
Yeugh.
Oh! Eoahoh! Hoh.
It was-ah-it was before I was ready to-
for it to fall.
Okay so if I go a little bit early,
then I'd actually falll...
generally...
I screwed myself over, I screwed myself over, I screwed myself over.
*tired sigh*
Oh god. Run. Run.
wOaH-oh. Run faster!
WoOOoOh god run!
*stressed laughter*
I made iiit!
Hah HAH! Where am I goin' now?
Please tell me that's the last
hurdle that I needed to cro-oh god.
Oh ga-oh gOD, what is this?
Can I please go down here?
Thank you! I don't know where you leads to, but I hope it's any better than where I wasss...
Ooooo
kkkkk...
That's, well, I don't kn-oh God
oh God NO! NO!
Oh no, you didn't tell meee...
(sniff)
You didn't tell me it was like that!
What a load of assssssss.
I'm a whiny baby!
[baby noises]
[baby cry]
(moaning)
Here we go here we go here we go.
Run for it! Run for it!
Run, Forrest, run!
Runnn!
Yeahhhhh!
Boink!
(tongue noises)
Ok, so...
Alright...
So that's-that's just
that's a whole lotta death right there...
Ah, that's
that's a bunch of death...
But I've got to imagine that around here...
Just, aaa-yeah, I was right!
Oh God!
Yes!
Suck a dick!
Suck it allllllll!
Burn you bastards!
So, I don't know where the hell I went...
Where did I go that I was off in Thwomp land, that I wasn't supposed to be there?
Because obviously I wasn't supposed to be there.
Heh.
I had a feeling that you could've like spin jumped on all those swamp- Thwomps.
I?
I got the new record! Good for me!
I'm getting all sorts of records here!
(evil laughter)
Oh no don't tell me...
(mocking voice) My princess is in another castle.
(normal voice) Oh? Hi! Hello princess! Oh!
I'm your hero?
Do I get cake and a kiss?
(sinister voice) And something else?
(normal voice) Oh.
It's progressively better rewards the harder difficulty that you go through.
Oh and here's everyone that made the levels!
Thank you: Isabelle, Liam@beast.
#beast*
Sebas.
Eva. Or pound sign.
Nyn-nyn-nyn-nynjas.com, Eva, fluojn, Fulbright, asher, dad.
Thanks Dad!
Joey, Kyla, MarceL the...
...cubed.
That Japanese name, Rawr and Jimster.
Ok! So, there we go.
Hoo, that was an adventure.
But now we're going to get a taste of what 'expert'-oh!
(clapping) Yay! I got a mystery costume!
The woolly world...nice.
Anyway, we're going to get a taste of what 'expert' has to offer us.
I have a funny feeling...
...it ain't gonna be too easy. (sigh)
It's still sixteen levels though.
Apparently.
Oof.
Things get dark and dreary.
A'ight, let's go for it.
Lets see what happens.
I-I imagine this is going to be very difficult for me.
But I'mma to try to get through the first one.
And if I can get through the first one in less than a few lives...
...everything shoulda work out.
(whispering) Probably not.
(Slightly louder) Probably not!
(Even louder) PROBABLY DEATH AWAITS ME!
(whispering) Just alotta death.
Ok.
Ahh why, you son of a bitch! Why would you do that to me?
(laughing) Why did you do that?
You can't just surprise me right off the bat with that!
Ok, thank you.
How am I supposed to be able to get in there?
How am I supposed to be able to survive any of this?
What do you do?
WOAH what the fuck I...
Uh...
What was that?
Did he intentionally put that there so it bugged out? Probably. What the hell?
Oh that's so weird.
Ok, can I get in here? Yeah, I can! Ok.
But this doesn't help me much at all, but, I could get in technically...
...right here.
Ok.
Damn it. Ok.
There we go, got it. Ok.
So now that I'm in here what do I get?
(slightly higher pitch) What do I get? What do I get? Oh boy!
That doesn't really help me much...
Ohh noo!
Why did you do this?
Why did you trap me in here? This is not fair. Screw you!
This is not off to a good start. These expert levels are going to be a biiitch
I don't know how anyone would be able to finish the...
like, SUPER expert levels
SHUT UP It's not too difficult! I got this
[higher-pitched] I got it!
Whatchu talking about? I got it
[ding-dong sound from door] Ok so...
Don't go there
That's bad- Ohh shit
[mocking Mario] Ohh noo hu hu noo ho ho hoo
[mocking] ohh noo
Aww NO, you troll! You troll! You troll [laughs] you trooollll
You trollll
Troll...
Dammit. Okay.
Now we need to get serious. We need to learn that there's tricks to every obsta.
Okay.
Is that the end of it?
AAAH. TRAU--AHA.
Made it.
Alright. Okay.
So we got that.
[cackling in game, game over noises]
[sniffle] Why would you do that? What else am I supposed to do??
So maybe..
Maybe you're supposed to go up here?
Ah! This looks like a thing.
Unless it's death.
It could be death!
It could very well be death, but this is a thing at least.
Oh god.
Oh no.
Okay. it's fine.
Woo! Woo!
Kay, got it, got it, got it, got it, got it, got it, got it, I got it, I got this.
I got this.
So what am I supposed to do here?
Okay.
Okay, what do I..
What does this mean?
Am I just stuck here for all eternity now?
I..
I don't.. [rambles]
I don't know, I don't know, I don't know guys, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know!!
Dammit. Shoot, I have 13 lives on this level alone.
Not a good sign.
Waaaaah.
There we go.
Now what happens if I just wait here for
something to come along here, because this looks like a track..
but I don't know if I'm just gonna end up waiting forever.
What is that??
What is that? That's just gonna repel me!
I'm not even gonna be able to get in there!
What is that?
What a load of por-pi-zork!
Braugh. Alright, screw this. I can't do it.
I can't do it, I can't do this!
God, the first level on expert I can't do?!
This is bull!
There's gotta be like, a special way to do this, but
not enough people have played it that there's any clues! There's no clues!
No one's commented anything on this!
Okay.
So that's all the time I got for Super Mario Maker here,
I will try the expert hundred Mario challenge
soon,
I'm just gonna need to think about this.
Don't look at me like that Mario!
You turn your gaze somewhere else!
Ple--put your head under your hat.
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
let me know what I should do in the next video besides the Super--the exper challenge.
But that's probably next on my list.
So thanks again everybody,
and as always, I will see you..
in the next video!
Buh-bye!